all right coming up on 5 37 on your
friday morning sherry did you know today
is national pet rescue day
so a lot of animal rescue centers are
feeling the effects of inflation as we
work our way through the coronavirus
pandemic mary jane belliesa is live now
at the animal foundation with how you
can help a lot of us like to rescue pets
and adopt them mary jane what's going on
today
well cheri you know today is a day
dedicated to raising awareness to help a
number of animals who need help and one
local pet rescue tells me that there
have been a few challenges for them and
other animal organizations to find pets
a forever home sherry miss rothy is the
animal coordinator at help save pets her
organization is no different when it
comes to experiencing inflation problems
despite their small staff they connect
with community members and other
non-profits and animal organizations to
try and re-adopt animals through their
hotline she says there's been an
increase with owners working longer
hours some are returning pets due to
financial reasons or inability to
provide care and inflation has height
the prices of pet care making it
difficult to provide food and veterinary
appointments
where they don't have a veterinarian
college here
to teach
new vets
so
what winds up doing is that the
what happens is that the vets here are
charging a lot of money for their
spaying and neutering
where the people can't afford to spay
and do their animals and it's it's
getting really hard
ms rothe says if you're considering
adopting it's important to remember that
a new pet is a huge responsibility and
she also mentions that there's a few
resources that are available in our
community including low cost services
like spay neuter and microchipping for
your pet including here at the animal
foundation reporting live mary jean
vallieza live local now